thakoon un an spécialiste des affaires
maritimes bonsoir à vous merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur ert france pour
en discuter
dites nous quelle est la situation sur
place mon avis le risque est il de se
fendre en deux avec les conditions
maritimes actuels et à venir avec et
comme vous avez parfaitement raison
parce que on prévoit déjà en anticyclone
odm a avec des formules où le risque que
le bas de ce garçon 2 est là et le rige
est très élevé le wac à chaud et échoué
depuis le 25 juillet comment se fait il
selon vous et que les autorités
mauriciennes est attendu aussi longtemps
avant de réagir et de demander de l'aide
à d'autres pays pensent bon la première
des choses il fallait respecter un
protocole maritime existants ils ont
fait la demande
et comme nous c'est la première fois de
l'histoire nous faisons pas face à une
telle catastrophe
on était un peu perdu et on n'a jamais
vécu une catastrophe pareille et ça a
pris du temps et aussi libre à qui on a
demandé à venir à nous aider ils ont
pris du temps et aussi le la mauvaise
état de la mer le temps les lecteurs la
mère a été mauvaise dans des dents
mauvaises conditions et le bateau a
échoué seul décide donc c'est d'un
amalgame de tout les choses 1 qui ont
qui aujourd'hui on in là à mort au bo du
la catastrophe
justement vous parlez de catastrophe
quelques uns pourraient être les
conséquences à l'avenir sur le long
terme de 7 ce qui se passe actuellement
donc on essaye d'abord on ne peut pas
jouer aller jusque-là éviter cette
catastrophe qu'il est bâti qui sera le
parc marin de
du sucre qui est aussi une grande valeur
du restigouche
donc on essaie ici à maurice
tout le monde se met la main à la pâte
les industries sucrières ont arrêté
leurs activités pour faire des abus la
bagasse les gens est suivi par tout les
moyens et donc des salons qu'apple qui
donnent des cheveux est il bon mais tout
ce qu'il y ait dans la mesure du
possible nous les mauriciens ont c'est
non on essaye d'arrêter de t'arrêter
cette propagation d'une qui inefficace
mais on dit c'est de minimiser de nice
tu temps en essayant de rester sur terre
ah non comment se fait-il que ce navire
et puis échouer aussi près de la pointe
d'esny donc le le commandant de bord le
capitaine du navire
plusieurs croire on a essayé de prendre
communication avec lui mais il n'a pas
veille des pompiers quant à l'appel des
autorités et ils avaient quand son
bateau est tombé dessus à lire ici
c'est à ce moment il a pris contact avec
les autorités mauriciennes
est-ce que l'aide qui va être envoyée au
chant l'aide qui a été envoyé par la
france sera t elle suffisante est ce que
les opérations de pompage sont elles en
cours notamment
il y a deux batteries qui seront louées
pour les opérations de pompage justement
aujourd'hui donc je pense qu'ils vont
commencer d'ici demain et l'aide de la
france et est venu je pense à point
parce qu'ils ont eu tout récemment
l'exercice en simulation à la réunion
sur une éventuelle fuite comme on dit en
anglais le et speedlings donc
et là je pense que aujourd'hui sera un
test grandeur nature
kib ont eu beau faire face c'est un ami
et c'est la possibilité d'avoir un
territoire français juste à côté de nous
donc ça nous aide je pense que l'ex
précise de la réunion sera à coup sûr un
atout majeur dans ce climat se passer
dans les jours à venir
facua non merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialiste des affaires maritimes